Okay, dann habe ich euch recht herzlich begrüßen zum Meteorababend.
Ich würde ganz gerne, bevor es jetzt losgeht, noch ganz kurz ein paar Räten festlegen.
Bestenscheiden alle das Mikrofon aus, außer mir, wenn ihr Fragen habt, dann könnt da gerne unten
die meisten kennen und vor der Funktion her.
Ja, oder es gibt noch den Chatbereich, wo man dann was reinschreiben könnte.
Aber am liebsten werden wir eigentlich die Hand haben.
Dann sehe ich das und dann kann ich auch die Frage dann reagieren.
Nach ca. 40 Minuten, also schon vorher, weil das ist eine Gratisversion zu.
Das heißt, so bei 40 Minuten ist eigentlich ein Fertig.
Man sieht ja auch eine kurze Pause.
Nutzbar dann ist die Grat und dann wird nachher wieder ein neuen Ding per WhatsApp schicken
für die nächste Sitzung.
Ich denke, das ist eine gute Reiche.
Kann ich aber den genauen Fahrplan nicht sagen.
Es kann sein, dass doch ein paar mehr Fragen auch tauchen und ein bisschen mehr.
Gut, dann würde ich gerne warten.
Bei mir heute Abend ist eigentlich die einzelnen Apps, die ich benutze,
einmal durchzugehen vordaffunktionsweise bzw.
bzw. Mastermöglichkeiten mit den Apps mittlerweile vorhanden.
Und was für Einstellungen da teilweise von mir gemacht wurden,
einfach zum da einen besseren Überblick schaffen.
einfach zum da einen besseren Überblick schaffen und am Ende,
gehen wir dann auch nochmal die einzelnen Daten durch,
speziell für Windwolken, große Wetterlage.
Also da machen wir dann schon nochmal konkrete Analyse.
Aber zuerst würde ich gerne die einzelnen Apps von der Funktion zu haben.
Nach ein bisschen mehr in das Detail, was jetzt die Prognose angeht.
Gut, dann würde ich da starten.
Bei den Bildschirm.
Bei den Drucken geht.
Gut, dann solltet ihr jetzt an meinen Brauser sehen.
Könnt ihr das sehen?
Ja, als Brauser vielleicht kurze Reaktion.
Bei euch ist es da jetzt.
Ich muss noch schnell mit den Funktionen ein bisschen schwierig so haben.
Ich glaube, alles klar, wunderbar.
Dann gehen wir da wieder zurück.
Okay.
Also, das ist der erste.
Windwolken, die meisten mit dem reichen hier,
bevor wir jetzt nachher aufs App, wo es Windie-App selber eingehen,
würde ich gerne euch die Einstellungen zeigen,
würde ich euch empfehlen, abzuändern,
wenn das nicht schon einige von euch getan haben.
Und zwar generell auch für den Wind.
Für mich hat gebräuchte KMH, Temperatur,
den Druck hektopast.
Kalte einfach so Grundeinstellungen hier,
unter dem Menüpunkt da oben rechts,
aufklicken, dann Einstellungen.
Und am Hauptplatz, vollliegen und könnt,
da ist der Einstellungen vornehmen.
Windanimaturnormal oder hoch.
Hoch ist okay.
Je höher das wird,
habe ich das Gefühl um so.
Unübersichtlicher wird,
die Tichte, meine ich, die Tichte.
Je höher man die Tichte macht, um so.
Ja, unübersichtlicher wird, dann mach mal.
Aber wenn man die Animation hoch einsteht
und die Tichte etwas höher,
dann kann man doch stärkeren Wind
oder weniger Wind ein bisschen besser unterscheiden
aus meiner Sicht.
Und man da so reinsummt, dann sieht man schon
deutlich mehr, mehr verdient durch Prümung
und deutlich mehr Wind.
Mach das, mach mal ein bisschen übersichtlich.
Hab ich jetzt nicht so gut erfahren,
macht Regen, Gewitter,
bzw. auch Niederschlag mit dazu.
Muss ich ehrlich getehen,
ich bin jetzt gerade jetzt für die Schweiz
noch nicht unbedingt so perfekte Prognosen gebracht.
Sie können zenträumlich bei Windi
tatsächlich auf Wind.
Ab und an, gerade im Ausland,
mal noch Wolken.
Und zweitwichtiger bei Windi
ist sicher die Temperatur.
Das ist nämlich ein cooles Beispiel,
gerade heute um den Pöwen vielleicht
bei schwierigeren Situationen,
wenn es dann weniger wie 4 Hektopascal hat,
nur ablesen zu können
mit der Bratur die Verrennt zwischen Süd,
Alpenhauptkampf und Nördlich.
Und immer, dass man da eine ordentliche
die Verrenntraben jetzt sollte,
dann immer die Höhe dazun,
wenn das hier rechts dann einstellen,
die Höhe auf ca. 1000 Meter nehmen.
Und man zum Beispiel sehr gut,
dass man da eine Dake, die Verrenntraben
und da habe ich auch wirklich dafür
sehr stark im Gangeort.
Also wie gesagt,
ihr habt da mit nur noch die Höhe
auch auf den jeweiligen Wind,
beispielsweise, wo er auswählen kann,
macht es für uns natürlich
sehr gut.
Wir können mal deutlich höher gehen
und raue ein bisschen mehr rauszumen.
Es klart, wie in die wirklich alle Opfernen verhandelt.
Und man kann wirklich sehr gut
stark Windbänder erkennen,
wenn man da jetzt mal auf
einer geringere Höhe gehen,
wo es so ein bisschen spannender wird.
Aber vielleicht einmal 1000 Meter,
und dann kann man mit einem Blick
kommen, bei Wind mit sehr gut ausmachen.
Die Dake ist jetzt der Wind,
vielleicht in unserem Raum
und wo ich da das neke,
doch derkere Windband.
Ist es in unmittelbarer Nähe verlohnt
oder wird hier
gesehen,
oder wohl gemerkt,
auch geringer Höhe von 1000,
knapp 1000 Meter.
Ja, im Mittelland,
oder?
Also das macht Winden für mich,
eigentlich schon zu einer
ganz speziellen Darstellung,
wenn man wirklich sehr breit
sehen kann,
wo er weniger Wind hat.
Also finde ich ganz lässig
und dann macht sie genau
sehr gut sichbar.
Anhand wir
die Möglichkeit,
verdiedene Wettermodell auszuwählen.
Wir haben noch zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit,
gleich den Starblätter mit einzubländen,
wobei das auch wird nicht.
Man kann auch mal den Wind mit Anzeige
und Stärke vor allem angeben lassen.
Und ich aber mache das nachher wieder
ein bisschen unübersicht-licher,
um nämlich da am Anfang
immer sehr wenig generelle Informationen mit rein.
Was ich vor eingestellt habe,
das permanent auch leuchtet,
ist die Partikelanimation.
Ich denke,
das ist bei den meisten der Fall,
was ihr aber noch entdellen können,
aus meiner Sicht aus sinnvollisch,
die Idubaren,
also die Linien mit gleichem Druck.
Und anhand vor dem kann man nämlich auch schon sehr viel ablesen.
Und das Kuhle,
da unten mit der Eidakte.
Kann man daneben auch noch ein bisschen vorausgehen
und trauen,
wie sich denn hoch und eftrug generell verschieben.
Also finde ich ganz lässig.
Man kann dann wirklich auch weitem voraus,
das ganze mal anderen Ort zu bekommen.
Das wissen selber,
das würde ich jetzt mal nicht für ware Münze nehmen,
alles, was mehr wie drei Tage hinaus ist.
Es ist reine Spekulation für mich und oben.
Aber sicher mal gut zu den aus meiner Dichte,
der hier freich,
die Idubaren,
wo mache ich die permanent eingestellt.
Und je nach Modell,
also es gibt unterschiedlichste Wettermodelle.
Ihr könnt dann auch sauen,
man die aktualisiert werden,
müsste dazu dann auch den Infobatten klicken.
Dann haben wir dadurch jeweilige Modelle
mit dem Gratster, mit den gerechnet wird,
9 Kilometer Raster Europäisches Modell.
Und dann wird auch das Ganze aktualisiert wird,
exakt beziehungsdunten Interval.
Was eigentlich nicht so schlecht ist,
dann wird der Interval aber dann ist der auch,
okay, in ca. 13 Stunden kommt der Aptäter.
Das heißt, es macht nicht unbedingt Sinn,
alle paar Minuten reinzuschauen.
Meine Schließung,
hier ist das Ganze ein paar Mal über dem Tag hinweg,
abgedeitet.
Und die Infokönter da herausnehmen,
wenn wir dann da mal auf der reingehen,
da hat euch gut von deutschen Wetterdienst gehen,
das geht da aber für alle drei Bits.
Und aktualisiert,
also deutlich kürzere Intervalen.
Man will aber auch schon,
dass das deutschen Modell auch nicht so einen großen Bereich absteckt,
wenn man ihn vor allem unterwegs ist unten.
the European Modell mit dem 3,3 Kilometer Raster nicht.
Dann muss man dann wieder etwas,
größer gehen,
Eiken EU mit 3 Kilometer,
oder mit 3 Kilometer.
Also, das ist der Modelle.
Ich persönlich arbeite am Anfang,
um mir mal einen
mit dem European Modell als Grundbasis.
Ich habe das kleine Artiger vor,
bei uns in der Flight
oder besser gesagt im Alpenraum,
da nehme ich dann wirklich sehr, sehr gerne das ICON D2.
Das passt vor der Häufigkeit doch sehr gut
und in der Katze und Region,
dass die Probenen mussten doch wirklich sehr aufzutressen,
auch nicht immer,
sondern auch alles von uns.
Wir haben jetzt zu den Infos,
das sind alle dort herausnungen und die verliebene Modelle
dann müssen wir da auch für eure Regionen
dann mit einer maler abschleichen feststellen,
was es für euch besser ist oder zu dem Finder.
ganz, ganz coole, ja auch über die ganze Woche hinweg ist eine allgemeine Möglichkeit,
das Wetter noch differenzierter angeschauen, also mal nicht nur den Wind, sondern generell
ein bisschen alles im Überblick, normal auch in die Region, dann hat es da eine Möglichkeit
um ein speziell im moment wo man, normalerweise wieder an, wird dann geöffnet,
da habt ihr dann ganz einfach, wo ich in den Sonnen, die bohle, ihr habt mal den
boden, da mit rein geblendet, ihr habt gar nieder, lag mit eingeblendet, aber
das ist doch eher gröberin, prognosen gedacht, für uns im speziellen, man kann es
prognanthematogramme aufrufen, oder was für uns eigentlich sogar noch ein bisschen
besser ist, weil auch noch der Wind, der verliert da über die Höhe mit rein geblendet wird,
das ist das sogenannte Erkram, also ihr könnt da sehen, die verdienten Hö
und einfach sind eigentlich sehr gut und spannend, auch da könnt ihr dann mit den eintenden
Modellen widfen und dann erhaltet ihr die Prognote von denen, das Amerikanische Modell
wird das Modell was schon am längsten aufzeichnet, also am meisten Daten vorhanden sind,
hat allerdings auch das größte Raster mit 22 Kilometern und das nehme ich tatsächlich
nur noch mit den Gebrauchen, wenn ich noch länger wie eine Prognose anschaue, alles
und das ist dann aus meiner Sicht dann mittlerweile doch eher ungenau geworden und jetzt kommt
man eine ganz coole Funktion dabei, der Möglichkeit, also ihr geht hier unten, ich habe
eines einst, ein Funde vorher da, das ist nur möglich, wenn man das Abo gelöst hat bei Windy,
das größte, ich bin Euro in dem Wast, also wirklich Nusdorja, muss man sich überhaupt enttreten
auf 100 Wertes oder nicht, aber jetzt kommt der ganz viele Funktion und zwar kann man hier
mit vergleichen kann man jetzt die ganzen Modelle miteinander vergleichen auf den eintenden Tag,
das heißt, wenn hier wir uns für den morgigen Tag praktisch allen Modellen ein Nürnflag
vorher gesagt, wir machen davon ausgehen, dass das auch so kommt, aber wenn das alle
hatte, mit ihnen groupsiance, du konntet sie sichלא da bleiben, denn siehirig pillowenen zu
mede-fin, du botale務inde
und dasoooo
also
auch
oder
auch zu den ja welchen Modelle Nobel verannten Ort funktionieren.
Aber jetzt finde ich jetzt wiederum eine sehr, sehr coole Funktion.
Ja, bin die noch ein ganz spittelles Fuhlmann jetzt, die Thermik noch analysieren möchte.
Alles ist das ich ja ein bisschen wieriger, aber man muss wirklich mehr vom Emogramm verstehen.
Ich mache mal im Wald, wie wenn man da rein schwitzen.
Und ich hier in unserem Region auf den drei Boden gehe, mache das im Klimt.
Dann ist hier raus, ok, klicken und dann öffnet ich noch einmal ein Raster mit verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Und dann müsst ihr auf ganz unten eine Rologie gehen und dann öffnet ich den Fuhlmann für den Emogramm oder den,
so etwas zu sagen und ich habe das bei unten auf die QT gestellt, das man kann die normale Anbieten,
das ist ein langer nicht nur weit oder man kann das Ganze auf die Tieren.
Also was ich noch benutze, mit dem habe ich gelernt, umzugehen.
Und dann kann man dort eigentlich auch die Temperaturkurve dort unten analysieren.
Diejenigen, die können oder brauchen, die können mindestens anhand vor der Temperatur der Fuhlmannkurve,
amick oder eben nicht amick einordnen.
Also da ist jetzt noch eingestellt, das EFF-Modell, cool, da kann man wirklich zwischen den einzelnen Modellen flitzen.
Und man sieht, dass das deutsche Modell schon ganz anders strechnet, also jetzt das Amerikanische.
Und was für euch eigentlich sehr gut tichtbar ist, ist diese gute Kurve, da kann man schauen, wie steil geht die Kurve nach oben,
nehmt die Temperaturkur ab, oder haben wir wieder unten eine Fuhnahme, also eine Investition drinnen,
dann können auch mit einem Blick schauen, wie weit sind die Temperatur und die Temperatur und die Fuhlmannkurrausende.
Das heißt, gibt es weniger Wolkenbildung oder wie dort oben eine permanent Wolkenbildung?
Mit Fuhlhab links an den Balken, an der höheren Linie sozusagen auch noch einen Anzeichen für die Bewegung.
Also ist eigentlich sehr viel Informationen vorhanden und muss es halt herauslesen können.
Bei dem Skute gibt es eben die Temperaturlinien, wo die Ergonalang geordnet und braucht auch vielleicht auch nicht gewisse Zeit,
bis man da mal sich vertraut gemacht hat.
Aber für mich persönlich ist sicher eigentlich der besten Fuhl, um jetzt sich da auf den entsprechenden
Tag, der mich vorzubereiten.
Gut, also ihr seht, eigentlich nügend sehr, sehr viel von Personen.
Beim Wind, wenn die einkrennen Höhen, durchspielen, ist halt so ein kleineres Rast,
um so ein weniger weit von dir in die Kuchen flicken.
Und bei der Seite, ich bin auch bedenkt mit der Höhe.
Das geht jetzt hier noch, aber bei dem 1,3 Kilometer Raster,
dann könnt ihr meines Wissens eben nur den Bodenwind anfauen.
Was jetzt vielleicht für den Bildung gut geht,
mal geht nun in reinen Bodenwind,
aber an Gründen brauchen wir nicht so wirklich viel prognosen Träten mit oben.
Aber je nach Raster könnt ihr eben nicht weit in die Zukunft flicken.
Um ein periliger Anfang immer für weit in die Zukunft flicken zu können.
Trotzdem, wie weit, man kann mit der meine Flicken können.
Und dann wenigstens einmal eine Planung machen zu können,
und das Europäische Raster und dann je nach Ort,
seit dem Spanien hab ich unten, hab ich das Zeig,
ein EU-Schnippen genommen.
Mal schnell da drauf.
Und hat dem Spanien auch funktioniert,
wobei in Spanien, wenn die eigentlich von der Prognose her,
mich oft nicht gut funktioniert hat.
Also da地in müsste wirklich je nach Ort dann ausflicken,
wie zuverlässig die Prognose ist.
In Indien, super.
In Spanien jetzt nicht ganz so gut.
Da war dann das zweite App auf das mal gleichzusprechen kommen,
deutlich besser.
Ich sag mal, die Trepperkote war wirklich höher.
Aber eben, wie gesagt, das rein und rauszumhen,
und bereichet wirklich auch nicht immer von oben herab beginnen,
also weiter rauszuzumhen,
und dann immer weiter instill teilzugehen.
Das ist sowieso für jede Prognose da von Vorteil.
Daumen keine da keine Hände.
Alles gut, wunderbar.
Okay.
Eigentlich tun wir alle, wie gesagt,
auch so viel möglich,
auch da mal durch.
Man kann sich da ein bisschen verlieren.
Jetzt gerade verwolken,
bieten Bilder noch mit Zunehmen, Empfehlen.
Aber gerade im Ausland,
sehr selten gepasst,
nimmt da die Prognose wirklich mit Vorsicht.
Man kann da auch nicht nach oben auch.
Diese Ansicht gehen wollten,
weil keine Prognose weg vom St. Mieten bildet,
weil man weiter in die Zukunft trauen möchte.
Und hat leider nicht so gut funktioniert,
im Ausland an so einem Tag,
wie jetzt,
das Team verwolken,
reinkommen mit ihrer Front,
da stimmt auch da die Prognose,
aber an Tagen muss man das Niergeist,
bin ich bisher nicht so nötig gefahren.
Das gleiche gilt ebenfalls für...
Das ist eine Öffnung für den Niederschlag im Generen.
Da gehen wir nachher bei den anderen Äpfchen,
weil ich es weiter drauf bin.
Gut.
Dann würde ich da Windy
einmal vorlassen
und einmal aufs Nied der Äpfchen.
Das wäre
ein Medioperator.
Das ist eine meiner absoluten Lieblings-Apps,
weil es einfach
vor der Darstellung hier aus meiner Sicht
schon fast nichts besseres gibt,
nichts einfache Rös,
nichts übersichtlichlicher Rös,
damit eigentlich,
wir haben mit 10 Minuten
gerade bemachigtig worden,
also mal nach 8 Minuten.
Und dann werde ich dann nachher
einmal eine neue Sitzung starten,
auf jeden Fall.
Das Auszahlungspflichtig,
wenn man die Basis beziehungsweise
die gratis Version nutzt,
dann ist ein Algorithmus in der Nähe.
Ügend ein Tag,
oder man sogar mehrere Daten spiert,
das heißt, und man weiß auch nicht,
welchen Tag,
es kann der morgige Tag sein,
es kann der heutige Tag sein,
man ist quasi,
wenn man permanentraut ist,
dann kannst du die Basis,
aber auch da,
das kostet 24 Euro,
wenn das ganze Jahr
eigentlich sehr preiswert
und bietet eigentlich gerade
für den normalen Piloten.
Das war so alles im Haus,
den prognose,
der mit prognose,
Wolkenmenge,
Niederschlagsmenge,
Thermiküren,
mit Farben,
unter Teilen, sogar eine Stärke.
Also es ist eigentlich alles vor allem,
und vorne vor dem,
ja,
wirklich sehr gut.
Was hier,
und ich ganz viel einfach ist,
ist den Gesamt,
über Blick zu machen.
Also man kann natürlich auch weiter
rauszumen,
aber so vor der,
direkt einen Ansatz,
wo er hat,
die Biste mit der Karamwind,
in die ich winke,
deutlich besser gemacht.
Aber,
wenn man da ein bisschen dreigeht,
und ein wenig,
wenn er das macht,
dass er nicht einfach
mit den Ort für euch anschaut,
sondern vielleicht auch,
in näherer und ging-
um mal abrufen.
Das ist jetzt passiert.
Habt ihr noch meinen Bild?
Ja.
Könntet ihr vielleicht schnell jemand angeben
und aufnehmen?
Ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Ihr habt noch meinen Bild.
Ich bin mir schnell gefilmt.
Wie gesagt,
also,
nicht nur bei euch,
an dem Ort orientiert,
sondern auch dem Wind,
dann in der Umgebung an dem Haus.
Und wenn ihr,
wenn ihr das auch zum Arzt schon öffnet,
aber bei euch,
dann sieht man das so aus.
Und wenn ihr da recht auf das Diagramm kriegt,
dann erhaltset ihr
die Klarstellung.
Ihr habt die Höhe,
ihr habt den ganzen Tag dabei.
Also,
von 758 bis am Arn
rausgezelt,
und nicht
am Wind in der verschiedenen Höhe
mit Beilen,
vor der
Stärke der Wind umso dicker und jetzt
im Klar,
in der Stärke der Wind
sogar ein bisschen
des Kleidflussenden ausgewischtet.
Also,
grün und gelb,
noch Fußball
und bei Rohransch und Witz,
und dann nicht mehr Fußball.
Und ich finde das einfach
vor der Darstellung her
extrem gut.
Man kann sofort mit einem Blick
erkennen,
in welcher Höhe er hat,
enorm gut.
Oder wir hier,
beispielsweise,
die Uhr,
dann in der Wind,
extrem gut.
Was man bei Meteoparabo aufpassen muss,
und aufpassen muss,
einfach bedenken muss,
man kann gut 5 bis
mal 10,
mal sogar 15 Grad abziehen.
Also,
ich bin gerne zu stark,
aber das ist mir lieber,
also umgekehrt.
Und,
mache ich aber sehr gut
funktioniert,
Richtung.
Und,
ich habe erst gestern,
wie man hat,
ich bekommen,
von Peter,
meinen Spanien,
immer noch unterwegs ist,
und da hat Meteoparabo
wieder eine absolute
Punktprobung sie gebracht.
Also,
mit der Zeit,
mit der Stärke sogar,
und der Wind Richtung,
dann kann man natürlich,
dann auch sehr,
sehr gut,
arbeiten,
entscheiden,
und gut geht man hin.
Und Meteoparabo,
muss ich sagen,
trifft jetzt bei uns,
gerade gab es schon,
gar nicht so oft,
so gut zu,
aber im Ausland hervorragend.
Also,
sollte dir als Ausland gehen,
ist eine Meteoparabo,
sachstündlich,
weil das extrem gut so ist.
Und,
das tolle ist,
ab mit der Ton,
mit einem Blick,
noch die Wolkenmenge
oder in der Region Stuttgart,
wo ich geangetätelt ist,
das geht dann hier,
die zu Wolken,
wenn zu Nuderslaat hat,
eher mal zurück auf
weiter,
da muss ich auch Nuderschlag haben,
das geht dann raus,
die Wolken,
in Stuttgart,
jetzt,
da ich weiter ganz runter,
und dann geht das da drunter,
mit Nuderschlag,
mit der Ton,
eigentlich alles noch drauf,
und das ist wirklich im Überblick
für den ganzen Tag.
Da ist es mittlerweile so,
das war am Anfang mit,
mit ganz gegeben,
aber jetzt ist so,
dass ich das am Anfang
mit dem Voraus anschauen kann.
Und ich finde,
einfach volle Darstellung her,
wo man schnell mit einem Blick,
ja, sich in die Überblick verschaffen kann,
wie es im ganzen Tag verteilt,
auch zu sehen hat.
Wenn man jetzt drückend klingt,
wo ja,
in den Winter eigentlich auch super ist,
aber,
wenn man jetzt da den ganzen
Donnerstag anschauen,
wird halt,
jeweils jede einzelne Mühe durchgehen.
Das heißt, wir müssen dann,
was ist auch 2.000 Meter in der Fall,
oder auch 3,000 Meter.
Also, wir müssen uns das merken.
Ah ja, da, am 6. am Abend,
beispielsweise,
da hat es auf 2.000 Meter
in Ordnung zu machen.
Das muss man sich da wirklich merken,
und benötigt natürlich auch viel Zeit.
Wenn man da wieder den Strom machen,
mit 2.000 Meter.
Wenn wir hier noch 2 Minuten,
wenn man da 3,000 Meter aufmetern,
dann haben wir mit einem Blick,
sehen wir sofort,
beispielsweise,
wann der Wind
unten,
zu nehmen.
Wir haben hier vielleicht noch in der Unterrundsicht
im Bereich der Wandmut
umgespätser,
haben wir da ordentlicher Windnahme
von der Absicht in Urges,
ja,
auch an der Sturm,
richtig extrem besunken durch.
Ich finde,
das macht es extrem schnell,
nicht wahr,
wann,
wann haben wir noch ein Problem?
Ja, mal,
es ist kein Problem,
sondern,
wann ist es noch unfliegbar?
Und wann muss man wirklich aufpassen?
Ich bin dir sehr, sehr gut.
Dann haben wir,
so oben,
rechts,
neben uns,
die Akram,
haben wir noch den,
wo wir uns die Tamik dazu sagen.
Also, auch hier,
können wir dann natürlich noch
die Einzelung
wechseln,
zu diesem KM hat,
los,
und in dieser hohen Funde,
ich habe ja wie man hier am KM hat.
Und da ist jetzt,
aus meiner Sicht,
auch wieder für den Benutzer,
aufgrund der Freundlich,
das M-A-Kram,
abgeändert wurde.
Das heißt, man hat eine ganz eigene
Interpretation von diesem M-A-Kram hergestellt.
Und zwar,
wenn man das tut macht,
mit dieser rechte Zustandkurpe,
mit eigenen Farben,
wie man die Schumbar macht.
Das heißt,
es ist eigentlich eine eher stabile Fichtung,
weil nur ein Portulgradient ist,
nimmt ganz nie mal,
oder ist mal mal vielleicht sogar gleichbleibend.
Wir möchten nachher mal
mitgemacht werden,
aber ich kann auf dem Malten,
dass es jetzt darüber,
wie ich hier mal über die H sahen.
Und wie du es tatsächlich nähert
und leuchte es nicht,
dass du da schon gleich so in Ruhe haben,
da du siehst,
da duacklich kannst du da,
das war's nochmal.
Da ist du zufrieden,
da du bist schon mal da,
da du bist okay.
Wie sieht man,
na?
So,
wo du da erschienst,
du hast das in den anderen Benutkern,
also schon fast nicht mehr. Nicht mal mehr eine Minute. Wir werden das dann gleicher
der Fälle stoppen. Geh dann nachher dann einmal auf dieses Emogramm ein und beziehungsweise
auf den Temp und mit ein paar Wochen. Das aber jetzt hier beenden und schickt